[Music]
what's quite distinctive about the
college program here is what makes the
university distinctive namely what kinds
of students it draws what kind of sorts
of faculty are teaching the courses and
the variety of course offerings I've
always admired Carnegie Mellon
especially and a chance to be here live
on campus get to meet the professor's
taking the courses that you see in
computer science and sound recording I
get a little bit of taste of everything
that I'm interested in I originally
toured the school last year and I really
like the environment so I decided I'll
try and get into the APA or music
program this year I did and it just
lived up to all my expectations I teach
introductory to psychology and I teach
social psychology the expectations of
the pre-college students are just the
same as the expectations of anyone else
it's completely different from high
school so it's hard to adjust so quickly
in a six-week program but um it's a good
type of challenging it's a good type of
stress the time management is the
biggest key because you don't get your
work done on time it's not teachers
aren't on you to make sure you turn it
in they're here primarily to learn but a
part of it too is understanding what
it's like to be here why I was looking
for a real college experience that would
give me some background information how
it would be like even though I'm the
loco I chose to stay in the residence
halls because I feel that that's a part
of college that you can't miss like the
whole experience is like camaraderie
within your floor within your building
just really like makes these rains a lot
better knowing all these people from all
these different places we teach because
we love to teach and we love our subject
and so we're really invested in having
students learning it's definitely for
students who like a challenge those who
want to be stimulated in a stimulating
environment many are energized by that
they love having people on their level
you know they feed off of that it's just
an impulse environment a great learning
experience not only are you learning
about Sciences or art design drama all
these great topics you're also living in
a college environment and meeting great
people great professors having great
times living here
burg